watching hisoka is like watching game of
thrones jammed into a single character
sex violence questionable moral actions
intrigue and power he is undoubtedly one
of the most iconic characters in the
history of anime and if you've taken
away anything from the videos on this
channel it's that popular characters are
successful because the author put a ton
of blood sweat and tears into creating
them as we will see hisoka gives you
goosebumps not because he's cool or
strong or because his bungee gum has the
properties of both gum and rubber no
hisoka is so damn intriguing because of
the psychological tactics that togashi
tied up in his personality using hisoka
not only as a character but as a
storytelling device that makes hansa
hunter what it is today and so hisoka is
purposefully designed not only to
manipulate the characters around him but
also to manipulate you dear viewer which
is why you love the story so much
this might well be the most challenging
character analysis i've done so far so
buckle up this is the story of hisoka
moro oh yeah
[Music]
if i had to break it down into one
sentence hisoka is a manipulative combat
addicted and powerful player in the
world of hanza hunter only acting on
what gives him the most pleasure the
apex of hedonism that were actually two
sentences yeah okay okay part of
hisoka's charm comes from the fact that
we barely know anything about his past
the only hint we ever get is that hisoka
grew up in poverty coming to cherish
even the humblest of luxuries such as a
piece of bungee gummy
now since this piece of information
comes from hisoka himself however it's
unclear if we can actually trust the
most manipulative person in anime
history with being completely honest
about his own past as we will explore in
a moment however it's very plausible
that he indeed did have quite a tragic
past and in this context i also want to
briefly mention hisoka's past as
provided by suishida the author of tokyo
ghoul while not canon togashi has
acknowledged it and might be working
around it in the future and so in case
you're not familiar with it we get a
short story about a heavily injured
hisoka being taken in by a circus troupe
how did he get injured where did he come
from where was he going we have no idea
all we know according to hisoka is that
his mother apparently had some sort of
proficiency in illusionist arts teaching
him how to use playing cards in various
ways working with the troop it becomes
clear that hisoka was an absolute
prodigy extremely confident in his own
capabilities and able to learn new
skills including them at an incredible
speed
he gets involved with the murderous
doings of the troops leader who murders
people for pleasure and he even forms a
sort of relationship with one of the
group's members while at the same time
simply enjoying his own growth and
dominance over others and in the end
regardless of hisoka's real intentions
or efforts he found himself with little
to no option but to kill the troops
leader and walk away and so in the end
it was actually hisoka who put an end to
the leader's serial killings all while
showing off his own cruel and pleasure
driven sight perfectly summing up his
character it's quite unclear in the
story however whether he does so out of
a sense of morale or due to his own
desire to fight and get stronger but
whatever the reason is it would seem
that he's destined to find and kill
strong opponents not only does his own
twisted desire compel him to seek them
out but even if he attempts a peaceful
life the bloodshed will find him and i
think that this shows really well that
the truth behind hisoka's hedonism might
very well be some sort of trauma from
his past turning him into the sort of
cult psychopath he's now
and while yeah hisoka is a really cool
character i hope it doesn't come as too
big of a surprise that the man has a
pretty severe personality disorder i do
talk a bit more about this in detail in
my analysis of sukuna a very similar
type of character if you want to learn
more about the psychology behind this
the bass line however is this hedonism
in other words fulfilling your every
desire is not the same thing as
happiness by focusing solely on the
present moment without any regard for
future consequences hisoka completely
stays clear of ever thinking back to his
past through combat however not only can
he gain control about who gets to hurt
him but he can also dominate people in
return and get a sense of importance and
purpose all while delivering a show for
the audience thus the true drive to
hisoka's character is satisfying his own
desires which is mostly finding and
fighting powerful people after all he is
a true tactical genius and a phenomenal
martial artist however i think the best
way to understand hizoka is actually by
looking at his nan abilities
[Music]
just like hilua hisoka also belongs to
the transmuter category its users are
said to be deceptive fickle and driven
by desire and i think there is probably
no other character that fits this
description better than our psychopathic
clown first of all deception hisoka is
arguably the best liar in the series not
only in the art of making false but
believable statements but in crafting
meticulous intricate webs of deception
that completely obscure the truth
actually hisoka literally means
secretive in japanese so you know it's
one of the most defining traits of his
character he is a true master of
manipulating people both in and outside
of combat often putting layers of lies
on top of each other hisoka does so to
divert attention create openings hide
his own weaknesses and sometimes simply
making his opponent suffer a great
example for this is his battle with
castro here also he willingly sacrifices
his arms to create an opening divert
attention and using his bungee gum
pretends to have supernatural powers
while at the same time hiding the fact
that he actually did injure himself
[Music]
all of this is to throw his opponent
into utter madness forcing him to lose
his cool and humiliating him in front of
the audience which ultimately leads to
castro's demise hisoka also predicted
that castro would die dancing now quite
understand huh
yeah i did
thanks hisoka also predicted that castro
would die dancing quite understandably
castro didn't believe the words of a
notorious liar and didn't give it much
thoughts meanwhile people who have come
to know this aspect of hisoka such as
ghanikhilua may find themselves easily
trusting of his words at face value only
to find it all to be a facade in the
ends in true transmuter fashion only
hisoka himself knows for certain what is
truth and what is lie
now hisoka is also extremely fickle
often what used to be a year-long
obsession of his can become irrelevant
for him in mere moments like with castro
or his infiltration of the phantom troop
and of course the most defining trait of
hisoka is being driven and motivated by
desire no matter if it's becoming a
member of the world's most dangerous
criminal organization in order to
challenge their leader or grooming young
boys into becoming stronger hunters just
so he can fight them in the future
hisoka is never deterred from getting
what he wants injury failure and even
death only seem to make it all the more
fun for him
this hedonism is expressed by hisoka in
so many ways but i want to look at two
aspects of this in particular here
sex and
violence
let's start with the latter hisoka is
literally addicted to fighting as in he
can't live without it and in this
context i think it's worth taking a look
at his relationship with the protagonist
despite the differences between ghan and
hisoka the two find themselves
inextricably drawn to each other on the
surface both appear to be opposites
right down to hisoka's appearance as a
scary clown the mortal enemy of
prepubescence everywhere but as the show
continues their differences blur into
similarity both gon and hisoka share the
classic shonen trope of the warrior
these are characters abnormally
proficient in battle learn fast and are
able to tolerate immense pain even
deriving a seemingly unhealthy almost
addictive level of pleasure from it
other such examples include kampachi
from bleach sukuna from jujutsu kaisen
and of course goku and vegeta from the
dragon ball franchise for these types of
characters there seems to be little to
no choice everything in their life seems
to lead them towards combat even if they
try to avoid it this desire to better
one's powers and define one's entire
existence through battle are not unique
to hansa hunter however while most
chonan tend to avoid the problems
associated with this stance togashi
calls out this issue by making it a
central part of both gonz and hisoka's
characters
they enjoy fighting because it gives
them a sense of importance having people
notice and fear them and gaining a sense
of control they have the power to have
an actual impact on the world as a great
example of this let's return to the
fight in the heavens arena where hisoka
without any real need to do so
sacrifices an arm to prove his
superiority satisfy his desire to
dominate his opponent and gain the upper
hand pun
absolutely intended this has a strong
influence on gong where later in the
greek island arc gone mirrors hizoka
sacrifice against genthru throwing away
a carefully thought out plan just to
dominate his foe
[Music]
but as if hisoka was not already a
masterpiece of a manga character
subverting a number of classical tropes
and rules togashi decided to do
something even more unusual based on his
immense self-confidence and as a way to
express his hedonism hisoka's character
carries a very interesting sexual
element as well and yes i know it's
probably a bad idea discussing this but
hey if you like hisoka that's part of
his character as well that guy literally
flaunts it in everyone's face it's like
with real people you only get them as a
package
cool who's josh
deal with it in general in an industry
that focuses heavily and often a bit too
heavily on female sexuality hisoka is a
rare case of a male being
over-sexualized now this is especially
interesting as hunter hunter is still
considered a part of shonen a genre
aimed at young boys with strong heroes
fighting against evil so not exactly a
scenario that requires a sexy somewhat
queer man to be involved here but here
we are this part of hisoka's character
is quite open for interpretation and
togashi meant it to be that way the main
point however has surprisingly little to
do with sexuality itself hisoka dressing
and behaving the way he does are a
visual representation of him not giving
a [ __ ] about the rules and embracing who
he truly is at heart and since he is a
hedonic magician well that's what he
gets for hisoka the line between
sexuality and violence is quite fluid
and often vanishes completely sigmund
freud would be proud the much debated
scene where he gets aroused just walking
behind kilo and gone can be interpreted
in many ways but what gets overlooked
quite often is the fact that hisoka gets
aroused just by thinking about fighting
hiluangon once they reach their peak in
strength and while this aspect of hisoka
might make some people uncomfortable
it's exactly what makes him such a
fascinating character hisoka doesn't
care what you think
[Music]
and so this refreshing role reversal
serves as a central element underlining
who hisoka is as a person now many of
these central traits can also be found
in the symbolism of his character that
you might find this either very
surprising or not at all had some
inspiration from the jojo series for
example a central theme for hisoka
throughout the story is the number four
like the 44 name tag or his number four
within the phantom troop four is an
unlucky number in japan maybe you know
that four is yon in japanese but there
is a second word for four which is shi
which also means death and death truly
is all around hisoka another theme is
that of the clown the fool or the joker
a very common trope in storytelling
however hisoka is not the warm-hearted
fool but the intelligent trickster
good evening ladies and gentlemen he is
known for his intelligence is close to
unpredictable and due to being
non-conforming incredibly irritating to
anyone who follows the general rules of
society next to hisoka another very
famous example is the joker from batman
who has reached a similar level of
popularity based on the very same traits
as a clown hisoka is of course also a
performer you only see him fighting in a
serious manner when he's actually facing
a very strong opponent such as crollo
otherwise his focus is always on
delivering a show for the audience
himself and even for his opponents
always with another twist and another
ace up his sleeve guiding the audiences
from act to act if you want to go really
meta here you could even say that
togashi has created a storyteller within
his own story but even then hisoka is
much much more than an interesting
character that enhances the story he's a
carefully crafted narrative tool shaping
the story and characters around him thus
hisoka is perhaps one of the most subtle
but also impactful examples of togashi's
writing brilliance by making hisoka
purely hedonistic with no particular
goal outside of being entertained hisoka
can easily adapt to any purpose the
story requires of him he is a true wild
card a true magician that can take on
any role be it ally or foe he is the one
that enabled gon passing the hunter exam
triggering his desire to become stronger
ultimately forcing him and kilowatt to
master nan
he is the one that tips off kurapika
about the gathering of the phantom troop
and on greed island that already has a
powerful antagonist he happily takes the
sight of the protagonists to advance
their respective interests at the same
time hisoka right from the start is
shown to kill without warning or
hesitation always oozing bloodlust and
as mentioned being fickle to the degree
that you can never be sure when he will
stop helping or what he's going to be up
to next after being absent in the
chimera ant arc where he would probably
have been a very bad fit hisoka
reappears in the next arc as an
antagonist to killua and the force of
nature during the succession war arc
as much as he's able to seamlessly adapt
to any story he's also a wonderful tool
to demonstrate the story's progression
and to power scale the other characters
due to his obsession with fighting we
see how powerful hisoka is giving us a
great insight into many of the
characters he encounters hisoka was
always meant to be extremely strong but
not uber powerful like netero or meruem
as a wild card he can be a powerful ally
or villain but is never meant to be the
main antagonist the reason he's so good
at showing us the progression of the
story and all the characters around him
is not because of his ever changing
wardrobe though let's be honest it's
always nice when anime characters bother
to actually buy more than one set of
clothes not only fashion wise but also
functionality wise
jesus i mean this is fashionable uh
where was i going with this again oh
yeah it's not because of fashion but
because of his flat character arc that
hisoka makes a great mark for character
growth for gone kilo and co character
arcs are always about a character
believing something about the world that
is false in a positive arc like heluas
it's about discovering this lie
rectifying it and becoming a better
person in a negative arc like gonz at
the moment of revelation in this case
his meeting with pito this central moral
insight fails to happen and the
character falls deeper into his lie
becoming a worse person for it a flat
character arc therefore belongs to one
that already knows the truth for hunter
hunter this truth is the fact that
people usually aren't either good or bad
they are grey and morally highly complex
driven by desires thoughts and the
people around them gone fails to realize
this and keeps believing that everyone
is either black or white
kilowatt understands this after removing
illumi's needle and is finally able to
love himself despite his faults
[Music]
hisoka on the other hand already knows
who he is and what he wants he's not
held back by doubt or shame
now obviously just because a character
understands the truth doesn't mean he
always does the right thing what makes
flat character arcs interesting is how
they act based on their insight and so
it often makes these characters a lot
more versatile and complex as they can
use this truth to do both good or bad in
the worlds thus hisoka isn't just this
one-dimensional character as some people
like to believe which is why i love the
shower scene which might be the single
most important moment of his character
[Music]
the narrator is basically saying sit
back turn off your brain and enjoy the
[ __ ] show that is hisoka's life and
since hisoka doesn't have to go through
the same process of learning the truth
anymore as the other characters we can
see their development in comparison to
the constant that is hisoka's character
and that brings me to the main point of
this video based on all that we've
talked about so far all the fantastic
writing and the character design the
thing that truly makes hisoka a
masterpiece of storytelling
is the fact that you dear viewer are
being manipulated by hisoka as well as
am i this becomes clear in all the
controversy around him we get so much
mixed information about this man is he
good or bad a role model or the worst
type of person relatable or repulsive
all these conflicting emotions are the
true genius behind togashi's writing so
is hisoka actually good at heart but has
a hard shell or is he actually just
cruel and selfish to the core
manipulating us just like the other
characters into thinking that he has a
good side or something in between we
will probably never be able to tell we
love him for his cool manner and his
fantastic fighting skills but despise
him for his cruelty and lies and so all
we can really do is sit on the edge of
our seats whenever he shows up not
knowing if we're gonna get the carrot or
the stick togashi has created hisoka to
thrust the central moral argument of
hansa hunter into our faces human
morality is complex there is no clear
black and white so we might as well lean
back and enjoy the [ __ ] show that is the
life of hisoka moro